de
Casie en France Jean-Marie Le Pen
persiste et signe il assume ses propos
sur la Seconde Guerre mondiale on en
parlait hier la condamnation est unanime
mais teinté aussi d'une interrogation
s'agit-il d'une stratégie délibérée et
dans ce cas faut-il en parler ne pas le
faire c'est risquer la banalisation du
propos l'évoquer c'est remettre une fois
de plus le Front National au centre des
débats Alix bouyaget Arnaud Boutet 7h51
Jean-Michel apti vous avez en face de
vous le président du Front national
bonjour Jean-Marie la Pen bonjour tôt ce
matin Jean-Marie Le Pen est déjà sur les
ondes le président du Front national
persiste signne il ne change pas une
virgule à ses propos publiés dans l'h
hebbdomadaire d'extrême droite Rivarol
oui en France l'occupation allemande n'a
pas été particulièrement inhumaine même
s'il e des bavures au bout de 60 ans je
crois que quand quand on la compare à
l'occupation d'un certain nombre
d'autres pays européens il faut
reconnaître que nous avons toute chos
égal d'ailleurs moins souffert que
d'autres pays comme la Hollande la
Belgique rien à ajouter non plus sur le
drame d'Ouradour surgan il y aurait
beaucoup à dire a-t-il laissé entendre
dans l'h hebbdomadaire selon une thèse
révisionniste ce sont des explosifs
dissimulés dans l'église par les
résistants qui auraient fait périr le 10
juin 1944 près de 650 civils et non
l'armée allemande on peut pas parler
donc je ne dis rien à dire je constate
que un certain nombre de sujets dans
notre pays sont contenus dans des lois
répressives qui interdisent la liberté
de pensere et la liberté d'opinion et je
trouve ça scandaleux Jean-Marie Le Pen
n'en est pas à sa première
rinterprétation de l'histoire en 87 ne
dis pas que les chambres à gaz n'ont pas
existé mais je crois que c'est un point
de détail de l'histoire de la deè Guerre
mondiale un an plus
tardsieur durfour
crématoire merci de
cette conséquence à chaque fois un
retour immédiat sur le devant de la
scène pour les spécialistes de l'extrême
droite cette nouvelle affaire s'inscrit
dans une véritable stratégie
politique c'est ça vraiment calculer on
peut pas parler d'improvisation
pour une interview qui a été donnée
comment on dit la presse écrite donc
c'est pas la télé c'est pas la radio il
y a pas de l'absus c'est très contrôlé
il a pu relire il a pu modifier chaque
mot contrôler chaque mot tout ça
vraiment est complètement maîtrisé et
donc ça relève d'une stratégie
indiscutablement après une mauvaise
année électorale et à la veille de la
campag le réérend Jean-Marie Le Pen
cherche avant tout à exister dans le
camp du nom et à reprendre en main son
parti ce nouveau débat sulfureux lui
offre une tribune une technique qui lui
a toujours rapporté des
voix